نشر الفنان محمد رمضان مقطع فيديو جمعه
بالرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس في ختام
جوله غنائيه له في نيويورك وتم الاتفاق
خلال اللقاء على اقامه حفل غنائي في رام
الله وسرعان ما تداول رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بعض الصور والفيديوهات ونشروها
على حساباتهم
[موسيقى]
كيف حالك الحمد لله رب العالمين
زمان احنا بنسمع عنك كل الاخبار الطيبه
والفن العظيم
في مشهد مخيف تعرض صياد للصدمه بعد ان
هاجم قرش النمر الضخم قريبه خلال رحله صيد
فيهاوا ووثق الصياد اللحظات المرعبه حيث
تمكن من التقاط لقطات مثيره للهجوم الوحشي
نشاهد
[موسيقى]
واو
تداولت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي صورا
وفيديوهات ترصد لحظات رعب من حادث سير
مروع نجم عن اصطدام شاحنه بعدد من
السيارات في نفق بمدينه العقبه الجنوبيه
الاردن الفيديو الذي تم تصويره بكاميرتين
احداهما في الشاحنه والثانيه خارجها يظهر
كيف فوج السائق للسيارات المتوقفه امامه
داخل النفق ولم يستطيع تفاديها
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم اعوذ بالله
من الشيطان الرجيم اعوذ بالله من
[موسيقى]
قرر الاحتفال بطلاقه من زوجته فتعرض لكسر
في ظهره ورقبته تعرض شاب برازيلي لكسر في
الظهر وعظام الوجه اثناء احتفاله بطلاقه
بطريقه غريبه وهي القفز بالحبال وهو وقع
الحادث الماساوي نتيجه انقطاع حزام الامان
بينما كان يؤدي القفز بالحبال فوق بحيره
في البرازيل نشاهد
[موسيقى]